>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Karen Jaffe: I'm Karen Jaffe.
I'm head of the Young Reader Center,
and I'm welcoming you to the Books
and Beyond for Young People,
sponsored by the Young Readers
Center and the Center for the Book.
I'd start out by welcoming our
special guests, students from --
hold your applause till the end,
and then we'd like to give
everyone a round of applause --
St. Peter's School, Two Rivers PCS,
and the Ludlow Taylor
Elementary, all from Washington.
Let's give everybody a hand.
[ Applause ]
They are our special guests today.
It's my honor and great pleasure
to introduce Cynthia Levinson,
who is no stranger to
the Library of Congress.
Cynthia is a writer of
nonfiction books and articles
about and for young people.
She's a former educator and
she conducts writer workshops
and play shops, which I don't
think I know what it is, Cynthia,
but maybe you'll tell
me at some point.
It sounds cool.
As well as presentations like
the one she's doing today.
She has written for respected
children's magazines,
such as Apple Seeds, Calgary,
Cobblestone, Faces, and Odyssey.
Her books include a children's
biography of Hillary Clinton,
entitled Hillary Rodham
Clinton, Do All The Good You Can.
Watch Out For Flying Kids.
How Two Circuses Two Countries
and Nine Kids Confront
Conflict and Build Community.
We were very lucky to have Cynthia
bringing several of the Israeli
and Palestinian children
that she wrote
about to our National Book
Festival several years ago.
People are still talking
about this performance.
It was amazing.
We've Got a Job, the 1963 Birmingham
Children's March, published in 2012,
is the backdrop for her newest
book that you're going to hear
about this morning,
The Youngest Marcher,
The Story of Audrey Faye Hendricks,
a young civil rights activist.
While we first met
Audrey in We've Got a Job,
this book focuses specifically
on her role in the event
and how a nine-year-old girl can
make a difference in history.
One quick bit of housekeeping.
Towards the end of the program,
we will have a question-and-answer
period
where you can ask questions
of Cynthia.
Please hold your questions till
then and wait for the microphone.
We have several people
with microphones
who are going to be walking around.
That's why we asked for that aisle.
And if you raise your hand,
Cynthia will call on you,
she'll point in your direction,
and that will let our people
with the microphone
know who you are.
So now I present Cynthia Levinson.
[ Applause ]
>> Cynthia Levinson: And
this was Karen Jaffe,
the head of the Young
Readers Center.
So I want to thank Karen and
the Young Readers Center,
the Library of Congress,
everybody here,
thank you very much for coming.
Now, Karen mentioned that I'm
going to read to you a book
about Audrey Faye Hendricks.
Audrey was a real person.
She told you that I
write nonfiction,
that means that the books I write,
I don't make up the stories.
The people and the
events really happened.
The events that Audrey took
part in happened in 1963,
which was 54 years ago, when
Audrey was nine years old.
Is anybody here nine years old?
Oh, then you're the same
age that Audrey was.
Well, think about that
when you hear her story.
Now, she lived in Birmingham,
Alabama.
Does anyone know what the
word segregation means?
Oh, a lot of people do.
You want to tell me
what segregation means?
>> Me?
>> Uh-huh.
>> I think segregation
means that -- I forgot.
>> Cynthia Levinson: Okay.
Well, you know what?
And I just realized, we don't
have a microphone right now,
and that's not fair to the
people who are videoing.
So I'll tell you, segregation
means when people are separated,
they're segregated from each other.
And in Birmingham, for decades and
decades, and in many other places
in the southern part of the United
States and in the northern part
where I grew up, people
were very separated.
Black people from white
people in particular.
And that's the story about Audrey.
Now, the book opens, as you'll
see in just a second, when Audrey
and her mother are cooking
a very special dinner,
some of her favorite things.
I was going to ask you some of your
favorite things but I shouldn't do
that till we get the microphone.
So we'll wait for that.
So let me start by
reading you the story.
I'm going to move over
here so everybody can see.
I'm glad you can see
that screen too.
Whenever Mike flew into town, Audrey
and her mama cooked barbecued ribs,
stewed greens, sweet potato
souffle, and Audrey's favorite,
hot rolls baptized in butter.
There's a recipe in the
back of the book for them.
Other folks knew Mike
as Martin or Dr. King.
Heard of him?
The Hendrickses used his nickname.
They did the same with
other ministers too,
like Fred Shuttlesworth
and Jim Bevil.
After Mike blessed the
feast, mama expected Audrey
to keep still during supper.
But when grown-ups talked about
wiping out segregation laws
that kept black and white
people apart in Birmingham,
she just had to speak up.
Audrey intended to go places
and do things like anybody else.
I want to eat my ice
cream inside Newberry's.
I want to sit downstairs
at the Alabama.
I don't want hand-me-down
schoolbooks.
But stools at the counter,
plush movie theater seats,
books so fresh they
crackle when you open them,
those were for white children.
Hush, says mama, nine-year-old
children should not speak in front
of company, especially
ministers like Mike, Fred,
and Jim who were bringing
dreams of justice.
Audrey knew all about segregation.
She knew to pay the driver at
the front of the bus and step off
and walk around to the back door.
Drink from the fountain with
the dirty bowl and warm water .
Use the freight elevator at
department stores downtown.
Front row seats cool water
elevators as white gloved operators,
the law said those
were for white folks.
Every Monday night, Audrey and
her mama and daddy and her aunts,
uncles, and cousins joined neighbors
and friends at Fred's church
for worship, fellowship,
and testimony.
She sang and swayed along
with the movement choir.
Her voice spirited and spiritual.
Black and white together
we shall overcome.
For once she didn't
have to keep still.
Then came testimonies.
White store owners won't hire me.
Ku Kluxers chased me.
Policeman called me names.
The hateful stories
made Audrey squirm.
She tried to tell her
mama, that's not right.
Shhh! How could mama
expect her to hush?
She had to make things right.
But what could she do?
When Mike visited Fred's church,
thousands of people crowded
around her to hear him preach.
In a voice as taut as steel cables,
as smooth as glass, he intoned,
segregation is morally
wrong and sinful.
That's true!
Fired up, Audrey sat taller.
An unjust law is no law
at all, he proclaimed.
Audrey had listened to
Mike explain his plan
at her supper table
and knew what he meant.
If a law is unjust, disobey it.
Sit down inside Newberry's.
Picket those white stores.
March to protest those unfair laws,
why even marching was
against the law.
Then get arrested.
Fill the jails, Mike exclaimed.
Fill Birmingham's jails so full
the policeman can't squeeze
in one more person.
Pack cells so tight that policeman
have to quit arresting people
for demanding their rights.
Audrey just knew Mike's
plan would work.
She twisted in her pew to see
which grown-ups would walk
down the aisle, volunteer for jail.
But they mostly stayed put.
Eyes staring at their
feet, hands on their knees.
Feet, hands, and knees didn't move.
Fill the jails, Mike pleaded,
meeting after meeting.
But heads shook.
All around her, Audrey heard, no,
best not break those
segregation laws.
Bossman will fire me.
Landlord will evict me.
Policeman will beat me.
If nobody protested,
Mike's plan would fail.
Police could keep arresting anyone
anytime for anything forever.
Audrey would never
be able to go places
and do things like everybody else.
One night, Jim announced a new idea.
If grown-ups won't do it,
fill the jails with children.
Audrey leaped to her feet.
I want to go to jail, she declared.
Mama looked deep and saw that
Audrey's eyes begged, please.
Okay, mama said.
Audrey strutted down that aisle.
She was going to jail.
Two mornings later, she put
on a fresh pressed pinafore
and shiny Mary Janes
with turned down socks,
protester's got to look nice.
In the meantime, her
daddy bought her a game
to help her pass the time in jail.
Her mama and daddy took her
by Center Street Elementary
to tell her teacher she'd be
absent, maybe for a whole week.
Ms. Wells wrapped her
arms around her.
Audrey knew she was proud of her.
She said goodbye to
her grandparents.
You'll be fine, her
grandmother said.
She knew Audrey would
be brave, so did Audrey.
Then her mama and daddy drove her
to the 16th Street Baptist Church
where the children were gathering.
Even before she reached the door,
Audrey heard loud voices
chanting freedom songs.
Inside, hundreds of big kids
called out to friends and crowded
around signs for their high schools.
Parker. Carver.
Her head swivelled.
Where was the sign for
Center Street Elementary?
She was the only protester
from her school.
The youngest child
in the whole church.
And she knew no one.
Audrey huddled by her
parents in the basement.
But when Jim lined her up
with the others two by two
and the door swung open,
Audrey straightened up.
She was going to break a law and go
to jail to help make things right.
Clutching a protest sign in one
hand and her game in the other,
Audrey marched out the door.
She stomped and sang, ain't going
to let nobody turn me round,
turn me round, turn me round.
We're going to sing
that in a little bit.
Half a block from the church, a
white policeman stopped Audrey.
He pointed toward a paddy wagon.
Sentence: one week in juvenile hall.
A matron locked Audrey into a day
room with two dozen other girls,
all older, all bigger,
all strangers.
Audrey sat down alone and
slipped the cover off her game.
I told you to sit down,
the matron yelled.
Audrey jumped.
She didn't remember standing up.
The matron dragged her
to a dark, empty room.
When I tell you to do
something, you do it,
she commanded, or I'll
leave you here.
Trembling, Audrey quietly followed
the matron back to the day room,
put away her game, laid
down her head, and cried.
Jail was harder than she thought.
And she wasn't fine after all.
By evening, Audrey
was hungry and tired.
For dinner, soupy,
oily, tasteless grits.
At night, a bare mattress with
one thin sheet for a cover.
Audrey and her cellmates
were led outdoors
into an empty concrete pen
surrounded by high prison walls.
The older girls talked together.
Audrey wondered what her
classmates were doing.
Ms. Wells would be
keeping them busy.
On another day, Audrey was sent to a
huge room and told to sit in a chair
that was so high, her feet
dangled above the floor.
Four white men glared at her.
She'd never talked to
a white man before.
Are you against America,
one demanded to know.
No, sir, she answered politely.
What do you talk about at
those meetings, another asked.
Our freedom.
Why did you march?
To go places and do
things like anybody else.
What was wrong with that?
Every meal time, Audrey
stared at greasy grits.
She could barely spoon them into
her mouth, let alone swallow them.
Every night, the cot's
wire springs jabbed.
Every morning, she had nothing to
do but sit alone with her game.
In the afternoons though, more
kids crowded into the day room.
Some days, many of them
arrived sopping wet.
A girl explained that firemen aimed
powerful hoses at the children.
Surging water spun them off
their feet and down the street.
They got up and kept
marching anyway,
until they too were sent to jail.
By Audrey's fifth day in detention,
the police couldn't
squeeze in one more person.
We filled up all the rooms!
Audrey practically jumped up
and down, she was so proud.
Watching television in the day room,
she saw black people stroll straight
into stores and restaurants
like they belonged there.
No one else could be sent to jail.
Everything had changed.
After seven days, Audrey went home.
Her mama and daddy
wrapped their arms tight
around her, washed the jail off her.
And for dinner, hot
rolls baptized in butter.
Two months later, the City
of Birmingham wiped segregation
laws clean off the books.
Audrey licked her spoon
clean at Newberry's counter,
like everybody else, black and
white together, like we belong.
There's a picture in the book
of Audrey as a real little girl.
This was actually taken
when she was 11 years old.
So she was two years
older in this picture then
when she went to jail for a week.
I talked with Audrey,
I interviewed her.
And here's a picture of
her when I talked with her.
And I have pictures too from
the real children's march.
This next picture -- well,
this one might be okay.
This is a picture of the church,
the 16th Street Baptist Church,
that the children walked out of.
Audrey was not alone, as you saw.
Eventually when they filled up all
the rooms, somewhere between 3000
and 4000 children went to jail in
Birmingham in a week in May 1963.
And Audrey was the youngest of them.
Here's a picture of some of them.
The next picture is
just a little bit scary.
Remember I read that the firemen
aimed powerful water hoses
at the children?
Here's a picture of the firemen.
And at the end of that hose
right there, the other end,
there are young people who
were being hosed off their feet
and down the street.
And here's a picture of a high
school girl getting arrested.
And here's one of the day rooms
that the girls were in, like Audrey.
But let's go back to Audrey.
She and all those other kids
were protesting segregation.
If you were going to
protest something,
what would you protest about?
Oh, I see a hand right back there.
Yeah, can you give
them the microphone?
What would you want
to protest about?
>> I would protest about
that if I would protest
that segregation is not
even fair for nobody.
>> That is true, segregation is not
fair for anybody, I agree with that.
Who else would like to say what
they would like to protest about?
Would you like to tell us?
Wait till you get the microphone.
>> I think everybody should
do marching everywhere.
>> Everybody should be
marching everywhere?
>> Every year.
>> Cynthia Levinson: Every year.
Well, that could be.
There's been a lot
of marches recently.
One more. Yes, right here.
Yeah, one more.
>> That no animals should be harmed.
>> Cynthia Levinson: That
no animal should be harmed,
that's something else
to protest about too.
I agree with you about that.
Now, you know that
the kids made signs.
I have some here, not
that they made,
but there's some protest signs here.
This is one that a kid made in
another book talk that I gave.
If you were going to.
If you were going to make
protest signs, raise your hand
if you have an idea -- let's
think, think for five seconds.
If you wanted to write a protest
sign, what would you write it about?
Would you like to come
up and tell me what you'd
like to write your
protest sign about?
Yeah? You want and let
somebody else go first, okay.
Would you like to come up?
Come up and tell me.
What you like to write
a protest sign about?
>> I would like to
write a protest sign
about that girls should have the
right to play in a boys' league.
>> Cynthia Levinson: Girls
should be able to play --
my handwriting is not
very neat right now --
in a boys' league, right.
Wait right here because you
are going to wear this sign.
There goes my pen.
Can you wait right here?
Okay. Who else would like
to tell us a protest sign?
How about back there in the green
shirt with the orange sleeves?
What's your protest sign?
>> Segregation is a sin that
people shouldn't follow.
>> Cynthia Levinson: Okay, how
about people shouldn't follow
segregation, is that okay?
People should not follow
segregation.
All right.
And let's take one more person.
You all right?
Can you stand right here?
Great. I think I see two
hands waving right there.
Yeah. Come on up.
Right over here, come
right down the aisle.
Good job.
>> I would say freedom for all.
>> Cynthia Levinson:
Freedom for all?
>> Yes.
>> Cynthia Levinson: Okay,
we're going to write down here
in my messy handwriting, freedom --
maybe I can write this
in -- for all, all right.
You want to wear the sign?
Good. Now, do you remember that
Audrey and the other kids also sang?
All right, can you stand right here?
Great. I'm going to play you
a song that the kids sang.
I started to sing when I
was reading the book to you.
And then we're going
to sing it together.
Okay, here it comes,
I think, or maybe not.
I think the audio is not working.
So let me sing it --
because it looks like --
all right, I'm going to sing
it for you and then we're going
to sing it together, okay?
Ready? Ain't gonna let
nobody turn me round,
turn me round, turn me round.
Ain't gonna let nobody turn me
round, gonna keep on walking,
keep on a marching,
walking into freedom land.
Hey, you know this song, don't you?
Okay, everybody stand up.
Just stand right where you are.
And -- okay, but you got to listen.
I can't talk louder than you.
Hold on. So you all are going
to -- you're going to stand up.
You're all going to
march in place like this.
And you are going to march up
and down right in front of us.
You're going to go in that
direction and then turn
around here and come here.
And we're all going to sing.
Are you ready?
You march in place.
And you march up and
down right here, okay.
All right, here we go.
Ain't gonna let nobody turn me
round, turn me round, turn me round.
round, gonna keep on walking,
keep on a talking,
marching into freedom land.
Whoo! Good job!
Okay, everybody down.
Thank you, marchers!
Yay for marching!
Very good.
You can keep those and
you can go back and sit
down with your school, okay.
Thank you.
Great marching.
Now, of course, you
should be in jail, right?
Like Audrey.
Isn't it amazing that she did that?
Well, Karen told you
that I wrote the book,
but I didn't draw the pictures.
A woman named Vanessa
Brantley-Newton drew the
illustrations for the book.
Would you like to see
how she did it?
>> Yes.
>> Cynthia Levinson: So this is --
I don't know if the
sound will work or not.
But you'll be able to see her.
This is a part of an
interview that she did
with the New York Times
about two weeks ago.
And this is clips from
that interview.
If you don't hear the sound,
it's okay because the
two of them are talking.
But you'll be able to
see her drawing pictures.
No, the sound is not
there for some reason.
In this part, Vanessa is explaining
that Audrey was nine years old
and that she had pigtails.
And Vanessa said that
she had pigtails also.
And she is saying, Vanessa
is saying to the person
who was interviewing her,
that when she was little,
she had pigtails too.
So she says in here, I
get Audrey, I get her.
And the interviewer
also asked Vanessa
if there were any photographs
of Audrey to work from.
There was that one photograph
that I showed you of Audrey,
that was the only one that she had
from when she was a little girl
that she was able to share with me.
But Vanessa said she
liked Audrey's sassiness.
Don't you think was
a little bit sassy?
Now, Vanessa used to
be a fashion designer.
She was trained in clothing design.
And so when you take a
look in the book closely,
you'll see that everybody
is dressed very nicely.
And you remember where Audrey
said that she had to look nice?
She put on her Mary Jane's,
her black patent leather shoes
with a strap and her white lace
turned down socks and a dress?
That's what she did.
And all the girls went
to jail looking nice.
In fact, one of the
people I interviewed
when I was doing research
for the book said
that she took her special going to
church underpants with her to jail,
because she knew she
needed to look really nice.
So can you see Audrey
coming together?
>> Yeah.
>> Cynthia Levinson: I'm
not good at drawing at all,
but I think Vanessa did a
wonderful job in the book.
And while Vanessa was being
interviewed and drawing this picture
of Audrey, people were
emailing her through Facebook.
There were emails from people in New
Zealand and Australia and France,
and they were saying that they
liked her drawing so much.
It was really thrilling.
I wasn't in New York but I
watched this while it was happening
on my telephone.
Because it was on Facebook.
In fact, if you go to my website,
you can find out where it is.
And she reads part of the book also.
And then you'd be able
to hear the audio.
There, there is Audrey.
So I've read you the story and
we've marched and we've sung
and you've seen how the
pictures were drawn.
Who has questions?
And remember, I'm going to call on
you and then we're going to wait
for you to ask your question
until the microphone comes.
Yes, I see a hand right here,
somebody holding a red jacket.
>> How long did it
take to make the book?
>> Cynthia Levinson: How long
did it take me to make the book.
It's a little hard to say because,
as Karen said, I wrote another book
for older kids before this one,
and I spent about three
years writing that book.
And then it took me probably another
year to write this book I guess.
But this book kind of depended
on my doing the other book.
I had do the other one first
before I could do this,
because it's harder to
write shorter books.
It's easier to write longer books.
So I wrote the long book first
and then I had to spend more time
so I could pare it
down to a shorter book.
Let's get a question over here.
Yes? Wait just one second,
wait till the microphone comes.
>> Do you get to choose
your illustrator?
>> That's such a good question.
I did not choose the illustrator.
The publisher chooses
the illustrator.
But she's a wonderful illustrator.
And she's illustrated
in about two dozen books
and she's also written
a couple of books.
She had a book that came out just
last year called Mary Had a Little
Glam, about a little fashion
plate, which is very cute.
And she also illustrated
a book about --
do you know the song,
We Shall Overcome?
We shall overcome.
She illustrated a book about
the history of that song.
And so I think she did just
a great job with this book.
And I did get to -- we didn't talk
while she was illustrating it.
The book was all done.
We didn't talk about it.
But I could email through
our publisher.
Because she had questions,
like what did Audrey look like?
What did her parents look like?
What are the food, the dishes,
that they served the food in,
what did those look like?
What did Audrey's house look like?
And I knew those things because I
had visited Audrey at her house,
so I knew all about that.
She wanted to know what
the church looked like.
She wanted to know what the
police cars looked like,
all kinds of things like
that, and I could tell her.
Do you have one more question?
Did you have one more question?
Yeah, okay.
Why don't we let him ask
a follow-up question,
then we'll go to somebody else.
>> So you visited her
house in Alabama?
>> Cynthia Levinson: I did, I went
to Birmingham, Alabama three times
to do research for the book.
Well, all right, yes, right here.
Yeah? Microphone.
>> Was Audrey more sassy
or her mom was more sassy?
Because her mom seems sassy.
>> Cynthia Levinson:
Was Audrey protesting
or was her mother protesting?
>> No. Was Audrey more
sassy or her mom more sassy.
>> Cynthia Levinson: Oh,
was Audrey more sassy, oh.
You know, I never met her mother.
I tried to meet her mother,
but her mother was very sick,
and so I couldn't meet her.
So I can't say.
But I will tell you that
they were both very brave.
Because her mother was very, very
active in the Civil Rights Movement.
But you know, between us, my
guess is that Audrey was sassier
than her mother, that's my guess.
Yes, what would you like to ask?
>> Is Audrey still alive?
>> Unfortunately, Audrey is not
still alive, I'm sorry to say.
She died of cancer in 2009.
It was very, very sad.
Whoa, whoa, that got
a lot of reaction.
Oh, goodness, that
caused a lot of commotion.
Let's see some more questions.
What would you like to ask?
We have another question.
Somebody needs to ask a question.
>> When is her birthday?
>> Cynthia Levinson: When
is her birthday, you know,
I don't know when her
birthday is, I forgot to ask.
But I am in touch with
Audrey's sister Jan.
Jan still lives in Birmingham.
And in fact, it was Jan
who gave me the recipe
for hot rolls baptized in butter.
So I could probably find
out when her birthday is.
I think we need somebody right here.
>> Did you make the book?
>> Cynthia Levinson: No,
that's a good question.
So the book is actually made by
a company, a publishing company.
And they helped me write the book
and they helped Vanessa draw
the pictures with the book.
And then they have these pages,
these like electronic pages.
And the book was actually
printed overseas.
I don't know where,
someplace in another country.
And it gets printed over
there and all put together
and the cover gets put on and
then it gets put in big boxes
and everything and it gets
on a ship and it comes
over to the United States, and then
they send it out like to bookstores
and the Library of Congress
and things like that.
I think back over here.
Oh my gosh, there's
so many questions.
Okay. I'm glad we have
lots of time for questions.
How much time do we have?
>> Was it fun?
>> Cynthia Levinson: Was
it fun to write the book?
You know, I felt honored
to write the book.
It was interesting and informative
and sad and scary and revealing.
And I felt proud to be
able to write the book.
Because, hold on, I actually
would like to explain this.
Because when I was doing research
for the book, I talked to Audrey
and I talked to her sister Jan.
In fact, I talked to dozens
of people who were children
who broke the law on purpose
in Birmingham and went
to jail, just the way Audrey did.
The others were all older than
she was, but they had done it.
And they were willing to
share their stories with me.
And I was very honored
that they would talk to me.
So that's how it felt
to write the book.
Let's go back over to this side.
Yes, have you asked a question yet?
I don't think so.
Okay, sorry, thank you.
>> When did she die?
>> Cynthia Levinson:
When she died, in 2009.
Oh, how old was she?
Well, you know what,
it's a math problem.
Figure it out in your head.
Don't tell us.
When you're ready, you
can raise your hand.
She was nine years old in
1963 and she died in 2009.
So you can figure out
how old she was.
Let's go over here.
I think right there.
>> How did you get
the idea of the book?
>> Cynthia Levinson: When did
I get the idea of the book?
I got the idea of the book
when -- now, Karen said --
Karen told you that I wrote
articles for magazines.
And I was writing an article for
a magazine, a children's magazine,
about music in the
civil rights period.
Like We Shall Overcome and Ain't
Gonna Let Nobody Turn me Round
and This Little Light of Mine.
Do you know This Little
Light of Mine?
Great, another wonderful song.
And I discovered this
story about Audrey.
And I hadn't really known it before.
I knew that people had gone
to jail in Birmingham in order
to protest segregation,
but I didn't know
that it was children who had gone.
And when I learned it was children,
I decided I'd better
write this book.
So I did. Okay, I think
a question right here,
and then we'll go back
to the other side.
>> Who made up the song?
>> Cynthia Levinson: Who made
up the song, I don't know.
Does anybody know the song Ain't
Gonna Let Nobody Turn Me Round?
That song, does anybody know?
I don't know who wrote that song.
That sounds like a
good research project.
Can you get on the Internet
when you get back home
or at school or a library?
Yes? This sounds like a
great thing to look into.
And you could let us know, okay.
Yes? Here.
>> Why did we have segregation?
>> Cynthia Levinson: Why
did we have segregation,
there's a good question.
For no good reason, for
no good reason at all.
White people I hope
used to believe --
and I wrote the book for older kids.
And in that book, I explain that
white people at the time thought
that black people carried diseases.
There were a lot of reasons,
like trying to keep black people
from having good jobs and
getting a good education
and living in nice houses.
There was no good reason for it.
There were just a lot of
reasons people told themselves.
I think we need to go over here.
We have a marcher who
has a question.
Wait for the microphone.
>> Is there still segregation
in some places?
>> Cynthia Levinson: Is there
still segregation in some places.
Well, I grew up in Ohio.
And in Ohio, we didn't have the
laws the way there were in Alabama,
but we had a kind of segregation.
Karen and I actually
grew up together.
We went to the same school.
And we had -- I'm going to give you
a big fancy Latin term: day facto.
It sort of means like, in fact.
In real life there was
actually segregation,
but there weren't laws
requiring it It just happened.
So is there still segregation?
I now live in Austin, Texas.
And we don't have laws about
segregation there either.
But it so happens that there
are a lot of black people
who live in one part of town.
There are a lot of Hispanic people
who live in another part of town.
And there are white people who
live and there are Indian people
and there are people
from Bangladesh.
And they kind of group together.
So we don't have segregation
that's required,
but it does sort of happen.
Do you see that where you live?
No, good, I'm glad you don't.
It's much better that way.
Let's see, let's go over this way.
I think right there,
yeah, right there.
Let's just wait for the microphone.
>> What other books did you write?
>> Cynthia Levinson: Well, Karen
mentioned that I wrote a book
about kids who are in a circus,
Jewish and Arab Muslim kids
who perform in a circus together.
And I wrote a book about Audrey for
older kids with other kids in it.
And I wrote a biography
of Hillary Rodham Clinton.
And I have another book
coming out in September
about the U.S. Constitution.
So we have one more question.
Okay, we have time
for one more question.
Oh, my golly, you know what, I'm
going to close my eyes and I'm going
to go like this and I'm going
to point in the very back.
Yeah, you, right there.
>> Why did the girl
want to go to jail?
>> Cynthia Levinson: Why
did she want to go to jail?
Why do you think?
Do you know why she
wanted to go to jail?
Let me ask one person
if they can explain.
Do you know why she went to jail?
Can you say?
Okay, yeah.
Right here.
>> Because you weren't
really allowed to protest,
and she protested about it, and
that's why she got put in jail.
>> Cynthia Levinson:
And she wanted to go
so they could fill all the jails
so that nobody else could be
jailed if they broke the law.
And so that's why she went to jail.
Thank you very much.
Thank you for coming.
And I think we're all done.
[ Applause ]
Hold on just a second.
We are being asked -- we're being
asked to sing one more time.
Do you know the words?
To sing Ain't Nobody
Gonna Turn Me Round?
You think you know it, all right.
You ready?
One, two, three.
Ain't gonna let nobody turn me
round, turn me round, turn me round,
ain't gonna let nobody turn me
round, gonna keep on a walking,
keep on a talking,
marching into freedom land.
Whoo, good job!
[kids singing] You're
doing a much better job.
We can just keep doing this all day.
Keep on a talking,
marching up to freedom land.
Thank you!
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.GOV.